careful viewer my spoiler sense is
tingling
since 2002 we've had six movies two
reboots and three spider-man now just
when audiences might be getting a little
sick of the franchise Marvel swoops in
to deliver a crowd-pleasing comedy
that's gonna keep spider-man in theaters
and to the [ __ ] Sun burns out of the
sky
spider-man homecoming Tobey Maguire
couldn't keep it up Andrew Garfield
couldn't get it started but Tom Holland
hits the ground swinging in a great
reboot that just assumes you're all
caught up on the MCU pretty sure this
guy's a war criminal now but whatever
complete with a glossed over origin
story an actor who doesn't have
premature old face and a villain who
doesn't already have some forced
personal connection to Peter Pan Liz's
dad all right two out of three ain't bad
witness a brand new take on spider-man
he's a millennial now who can't stay off
his phone
constantly blogs watches himself on
YouTube and has zero patience for
anything he's got all of the usual
spider skills plus a powerful new one
never facing consequences for his
actions whether he's getting away with
ditching detention hey where you going
get back here quitting on his team you
can't just quit on a stroll up and be
welcome back welcome back Peter
mostly imprisoning people Shinsuke ours
is bad it's my cards on that wrecking a
car wrecking a store wrecking a fairy or
wrecking his girlfriend's entire life
you can be sure this web slinger will
get off with no more than a stern
talking-to
you're a good kid and you're a smart kid
so just try to keep your head straight
okay okay don't get out here well the
older I get the more I relate to Jay
jonah jameson these are matters for the
entire city prosecuted you've seen him
as Batman and Birdman now prepare for
Michael Keaton's third winged creature
role as the vulture he's a blue-collar
guy who gets shafted by Stark Industries
and instead of filing a lawsuit against
a billionaire clearly in the wrong he'll
build a giant bird mech jetpack huh you
will be bored stiff when Fulcher fights
spider-man in bland CGI slugfests but
genuinely scared when he's just being
Michael Keaton are you scared I'm that
you're glad your old pal spider-man
showed up in the elevator though sorry
Uncle Ben and Richard Parker there's a
new absentee dad in town Tony Stark Iron
Man is back as the drunk rich stepfather
you'd expect him to be who will build
you a killer robot suit activating
instant kill send you into battle at 15
then literally phone in his parent aid
until you screw up enough to get his
attention okay it's not working out I'm
gonna need the suit back really Tony you
just fought your best friend over
keeping tabs on superheroes and you just
let your pet superhero run amuck is
anyone paying attention to the timeline
anymore this is approaching x-men levels
of sloppy she sends Bishop back in time
no just his consciousness into his
younger self so enjoy another super
smash hit whoo success was far from
guaranteed with two competing Studios
fighting for control six different
screenwriters and a director with just
two low-budget Indies to his name dang
it's like Sony finally cracked the code
on how to make the spider purse happen
let Marvel do the work starring Tom
Netherlands drunkle Stark
only winners do drugs chef's the
disembodied voice of Jennifer Connelly
you can call me Karen if you would like
Marisa Tomei vaulter or the unexpected
virtue of casting Michael Keaton
technically in the movie Tony ravioli
marry pixie Jane girl hey there Martin
Starr now not not your Asian sidekick
and Wonder Woman The Perks of Being a
wall of putting a set piece in an
elevator shaft spider-man can't catch a
break with that
I like bread beatlejuice beatlejuice
beatlejuice darkness falls across the
land the midnight hour is close at hand
I'm David pumpkins any questions
Halloween the night he came home